the girag an experience that's a good
combination of getting to the bottom of
[ __ ] is weed and martial arts yeah
that's a good combination 100% it really
is I do like a lot of my thinking is
just from like after I trained I just
sit there and just think about nothing
but you know what I mean you know ideas
come to me how to deal with situations
you know what I mean because it's just I
don't know it just happens like that
just flows yeah yeah it flows and I
think like the training that helps you
get all the [ __ ] off your back right
tell you right yeah yep especially for
me too cause like I party a lot and I'm
in a studio till like 5:00 6:00 in the
morning and I'm drinking and stuff like
that so to just be going down that path
and doing that every day but I look
crazy I feel crazy like I have to get
that off of me like I to me you know to
me that's why your gym is crazy but I
need to do something like that for
myself it's nice to have at some point
like that's how I look at you like the
og so it's like I'm not gonna go do it
tomorrow like hey everybody build me a
gym but you know eventually that's the
goal when I look back I'll be like I
seen Jose Jimenez
that's what me dude you train hard I've
seen your videos yeah Wow I get to work
you work out it unbreakable yeah yeah
your spot yeah that's a great gym it's a
really good gym Jay Glazer yeah he owns
that spot there a very impressive place
he put together an awesome place yeah
yeah it's cool the team there is good
like I said it's not all about like just
fighting and being you know the biggest
baddest meanest [ __ ] like they
really taught me about my body
mm-hmm a that's what they do they teach
you their whatever your goals are they
bring you you know up to that speed so
it's like I'll wait like 140 pounds ever
since I got out of high school and I was
like [ __ ] I gotta gain some weight and
they helped me out and does a snoop
train there too yeah
there's his video snoop sparring he's
sparring Daniel saw Rafi
yep Daniel's [ __ ] crazy yeah I know
that guy he left all his fights before
he's a tank
he is crazy look guys a tank nuts his
thing is like y'all I gotta get hit
I'm like all right Daniel you know he's
got to get hit to wake himself up yeah
Wow there is his barn with him yes Luke
was going at it so he's trying to take
him out dude snoop throws some good
shots them right there yeah snoop skills
he really does some glad Daniel duck
that one oh yeah I mean oh I guarantee
you snoop that's the honey right a lot
of people ever fistfight
oh yeah he's tall as [ __ ] - looking at
him like that look at those arms
yeah so that was so haha that Sarafian
that guy's a tank mm-hmm yeah he fought
in UFC for a while he's still fighting
still active yeah I think he's in Brazil
right now hazing yeah he was working at
the gym for a minute and he I guess he
chilled out